general jack keane he is a retired four
star general also chairman of the
institute for the study of war and fox
news senior strategic analyst that is
the big question general um
you know we keep hearing the
administration and others involved
saying don't give up on diplomacy but is
there a chance it might
might still work
well i think those it's pretty remote at
this point i mean the senior government
officials
are privately saying that russia is
going to attack
that the the off-ramp for diplomacy the
only way that could possibly happen at
this point is just because putin decides
to do that
but people don't see the evidence
that that's going to take place
largely because of what he is doing
with the disposition and employment of
his forces we have exquisite
intelligence on what has taken place out
here tracking what an army does on a
battlefield charles is quite easy to do
for a technology-based uh intelligence
capability that the united states has
and and and we're tracking that we're
not only taking pictures of it but we're
listening to their operational nets
their tactical nets etc so we got a
sense of what they're doing and if they
move out of those administrative motor
parks that we've been taking uh
commercial satellite photos of and begin
to move into assembly areas where they
get up gunned and they get gassed and
then they move into attack positions
that's telling you something uh and
clearly we are monitoring all of that
activity to that point general i i heard
reports
that now the manpower the russian man
power up to 190 000 and to put it in
perspective this is the largest uh
assembly of a military force since world
war ii i mean this is this is major for
people who really aren't paying
attention this is a potentially a major
military showdown
oh yeah there's no doubt about that
and literally uh warfare has changed
charles dramatically since world war ii
i mean we had about
157 000 in the normandy invasion but we
had
7 000 ships out there with landing craft
and about 3 000 aircraft
and
in uh in in the 2003 invasion in iraq we
had about a hundred 177
000 as an invasion force with air
supporting it
what what we have here certainly
is a ground force somewhere in the
neighborhood of 170 180 000
plus but the the precision nature of the
weapons we're using and the standoff
capabilities they have have dramatically
changed since world war ii so in the
pre-assault fires phase that would come
before the ground
invasion
russia will attack with air missiles and
rocket artillery those missiles can
travel actually thousands of miles with
an extraordinary accuracy
landing on the target
and and those missiles will be cruise
missiles and ballistic missiles he's got
bombers and fighter aircraft just like
we in the united states have that have
enormous standoff capability to deliver
very accurate fires while the tanks and
other vehicles are very similar to what
we we had in world war ii even those
vehicles
those tank munitions they can fire out
thousands of meters versus hundreds of
meters so warfare has changed
it's significantly more lethal
than what it has ever been
and it's considerably more precise in
the use of the weapons and many of them
are standoff weapons themselves that
brings us to the ukrainians being able
to defend themselves
i've heard you on this air
applauding the biden administration for
for actions that they've taken
many thought initially perhaps they were
slow to get the ukrainian military some
defense weapons
how how long or could they potentially
hold off this advanced russian army that
you just described
yeah not very long i mean they are
absolutely outmatched they they have
significant resolve and will
and we saw what happened in afghanistan
with an army that lost its resolve and
will
so they will fight but listen did they
have no defense at all against any of
russia's missiles think of that that's
quite extraordinary they have hardly any
defense against all of russia's 500
combat aircraft that they have
they just got recently
some stinger shoulder fired air defense
systems from the baltics they wanted
these air defense missiles
and air defense systems and anti-ship
systems
years ago from the united states they
certainly wanted it back in march when
they when the russians came on their
border with 70 000 troops we gave them
none of that we gave them some anti-tank
weapons and some small arms so here my
frustration has been this all along
i understand we're not going to put
troop u.s troops on the ground to fight
with the ukrainians because they're not
a nato country but we also said but
we're going to help them defend
themselves and that's what the
ukrainians want they didn't want our
troops on the ground but if that's the
mission then why didn't we go all in and
give them all of those capabilities that
where they
it would still would not be a fair fight
but where they could impose some cost on
the russians and pause them and think a
little bit well wait a second here these
casualties are going to go up
significantly we're going to lose
aircraft we have the potential to lose
ships
uh etc
and nate and putin doesn't want a lot of
casualties in this campaign he's
expecting us to go quickly and not take
a lot of casualties home to the russian
people
general real quick um
this nuclear exercise that was moved up
uh what's the what's the purpose of that
is this an intimidation tactic
yeah pretty much charles i mean this is
normally done in october it's done every
year they're just exercising their
strategic nuclear forces he moved it to
this date for obvious reasons beijing
olympics closed this the day after
he's going to be in a national military
command center at the time with
lukashenko
i'm not saying the attack begins
tomorrow but he's in a perfect place to
do it right and i don't know why
the president of ukraine is even
thinking that he would leave the country
while we're in this invasion window
because if if putin invades
the first thing he does is take control
of the airspace charles that's just
basic 101.
and
zielinski never be able to get back in
general kane uh please stand by uh and
great information i want to come back to
you but uh general kane of course not
the only one concerned nato allies also